التي تنتقدها واشنطن فهل هي عقدة
امريكية ام ان الولايات المتحدة
يا لها من حيلة ذكية. الانتقادات
الامريكية كثيرة وما اكثر الدول
وبين هذا وذاك وبعد الاتفاق على
تفعيل قوة مشتركة بين روسيا
ستستثمر وقت المفاوضة في تعزيز
صفوفها وتجميع قواتها داخل
بعدها وزارة الدفاع التايوانية
ان طائرتين مقاتلتين صينيتين
واشنطن تغضب من كل ما هو قريب من
بوتين. حيث اعلن موقع اكسيوس ان
شباب القدس لتعزيز قوات الكيان
الاسرائيلي عن ضبط منفذ العملية
استقرار الاسواق وعبر عن ثقته
الكاملة في الاثر الايجابي
الفلسطيني محمود عباس للرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حول عدم
بريطانيا هنا الرئيس الامريكي
يقول خطة رئيسة الوزراء
الخبراء الصدر ليس امامه الا
خيار التظاهرات والاحتجاجات. فهل
الرأي العام يعارض مبدأ بلد واحد
ونظامان وتقول نحن لن نتراجع عن
بلس بخفض الانتاج بانه قرار
تاريخي وممتاز ويصب في خانة
مسيرة انتحارية ايرانية الصنع
وزير الخارجية الاوكراني ديمترو
الحكومة بانها ميليشياوية تبعية
ستحول العراق الى العوبة بيد
لا تبالي بخسارة
والجزائر تدعم السعودية فيا لها
من جرأة لمحاربي الصحراء. موسكو
للقرار. وبسبب تشكيك بايدن في
سلامة ترسانتها النووية باكستان
الاوروبي والغاء مبدأ الاجماع في
صنع القرار من اجل اعداده
والتطورات. وصف وزير الطاقة
الجزائري محمد عرقاب قرار اوبك
الباكستانية تستدعي السفير
الامريكي. الرؤوس الصنعاء حيلة
سيعود العراق للفوضى? يا لقساوة
ظروفكم ايها العراقيون. الاحداث
قطعي. ايعد ذلك حقيقة ام انه حلم
اوكراني? اذا اراد الاوكران
الاجندات الخارجية. فما الذي
سيفعله الصدر تصريحاته هذه يجيب
الرد الروسي كان قاسيا يا سادة.
ومن السياسة الاوكرانية الى
جميع الدول الاوروبية. هكذا قالت
واشنطن ليذهب الامريكان باتجاه
قائلا هذا ما يمليه الماضي
الاستعماري المثير للاشمئزاز.
المستشار. ومن المقترح الالماني
الى الرد الاوكراني. كييف ترفض
للوزراء التيار الصدري يرفض
الاشتراك في هذه الحكومة. ويقول
كل هذه الفوضى للحرب تستعد بعض
الدول الغربية بخطط لمنع الفوضى
الصين في مكانتها يستعد اليوم
لولاية ثالثة في رئاسة الصين
لانضمام اعضاء جدد لكن ما
الفائدة من زيادة العدد ايها
ليقف امامه تحديات فيروس كورونا
ومنافسة امريكا واستعادة تايوان.
سيادتنا ولن نتخلى عن
الديموقراطية والحرية. لتصرح
لتشفى جميع الجروح العراقية.
وبعد انتخاب رئيس للبلاد ورئيس
بقدرات نووية ضاربة لشن هجمات
مضادة برا وبحرا وجوا. لكن
او بالقرب منها بحسب الجارديان.
فهل تأكد الغرب ان موسكو ستفعلها
على روسيا بحسب وكالة نوفوستي.
هناك كتب الايطاليون على
اقمار ايلول ماسك ليظهر هنا
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
غاضبة وتطلب من الولايات المتحدة
توضيح موقفها والخارجية
العراق يعود للفوضى. بدأت
والتأمت لكن الوقت لم يكن كافيا
الهندي بوتين الان ليس وقت
الحرب. والغرب يعتبر هذه الجملة
وزير الصدر كل من يشارك من
انصارنا فيها سيطرد الصدر يصف
من شي جين بينغ مصرحا بان بلاده
تحتفظ بالحق في استخدام القوة ضد
والتايوان تعلن تحديها. والعراق
قد يعود الى المظلم مجددا
تايوان كملاذ اخير رغم ان اعادة
التوحيد سلميا هو خيارها الاول.
الصيني شي جين بينغ ويقول بلادنا
ستنتصر في معركتها لتطوير
واشنطن قد تنسى امر التجربة
لسعادتها برد رئيس الوزراء
على موسكو. فهل اكتفى الغرب بتلك
العبارة الهندية? هم يا للعجب.
وبشأن تايوان. هنا المتحدثة باسم
الرئاسة التايوانية تعلن ان
حقا برأيي الشخصي لا اظن ذلك.
الهند تقتدي بالمجنون. العالم
دخلتا القطاع الجنوبي فماذا عن
السيادة يا هؤلاء ليأتي رد حاسم
صواريخ باتريوت الى الرياض. فهل
تستغني واشنطن عن اموال المملكة
من منافسة. نعم هي منافسة تكسير
العظام بدأتها الولايات المتحدة
القمة. ها هي الصين اليوم صاحبة
ثاني اقوى اقتصاد في العالم
ممثلي الادارة الامريكية
استشاطوا غضبا من كلام الرئيس
نصرا سياسيا لكن تبقى الهند احد
اكبر مستوردي النفط من روسيا
في معركة التقنيات الاساسية
الرئيسية. شي جين بينغ من وضع
فهل ستتحرش بيلا روسيا بحلف
الناتو ليعلن بوتين تدخل وخلال
للصين في خطابه التاريخي ليكتم
الجميع انفاسه. ويطلقها الرئيس
بمنع تصدير الرقائق الالكترونية
او ما يسمى باشباه الموصلات
وتبيعه للغرب بزيادة خمسة اضعاف
حتى انها لم تنضم لعقوبات الغرب
اطلق من اول غواصة صنعت وتعمل
بالطاقة النووية. يا لهذه الجرأة
تكنولوجيا ذات الاهمية
الاستراتيجية. وسنحقق فوزا حاسما
الهندية. هذه التجربة تؤكد ان
الهند واحدة من ست دول الى جانب
الاوكرانية في حال لم تصدر
الحبوب والاسمدة الروسية لتقولها
نواب من الحزب الديموقراطي
بالدفع بمشروع قرار يقضي بنقل
لتبدأ معركتها مع صاحبة المركز
الاول. بكين ضد واشنطن ويا لها
موسكو بصوت عال هذه بتلك وليس
النفط فقط بل النفط والغذاء.
ساعة الصفر الصينية. اصحاب
العيون الضيقة من القاع الى
والذعر بين السكان في حال تفجير
قنبلة نووية روسية في اوكرانيا
وزارة الدفاع الهندية ان البلاد
اختبرت بنجاح صاروخ باليستيا
الولايات المتحدة وبريطانيا
وروسيا وفرنسا والصين مزودة
انتقد ماكرون سياسة روسيا ها هو
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
روسيا? اي انهم لا يريدون
التفاوض مع حكومة بوتين بشكل
وبلاروسيا تصل اول من الجنود
الروس الى الاراضي البلاروسية.
ونفطها من اجل اوكرانيا ومن حرب
الطاقة لحرب الغذاء. وبالعودة
اسلحة امريكية مخصصة للسعودية
الى اوكرانيا وتعليق مخطط نقل
الحوار مع الجانب الروسي. وتقول
نحن لن نتفاوض مع بوتين. انها
الى روسيا هناك تلويح روسي برفض
تجديد اتفاقية تصدير الحبوب
مشغول بحرب اوكرانيا وبقضية
تايوان وبصواريخ مجنون كوريا هنا
محاولة التقرب مرة اخرى من
السعودية عقب قرار اوبك بلس يمضي
ثقة الفلسطينيين في واشنطن ليرد
وزير الخارجية الروسي الحقيقة
الارض. فالحل الوحيد كما تراه
كييف هو التغيير السياسي داخل
ديمتري ميدفيديف يوجه هجومه نحو
فرنسا ويذكرهم بماضيهم في
خرج المستشار الالماني اولف
شولتس ودعا الى اصلاح في الاتحاد
الداعم الرئيسي لاوكران امريكا.
قدمنا مساعدات لاوكرانيا اكثر من
الجزائر وما لي وتسببهم بانهار
من الدماء بمستعمراتهم السابقة
دائما مرة بالنسبة لكم ايها
الامريكان. واشنطن تواصل وبعد
تغيير سلطتنا فليحافظوا اولا على
تقولها الحكومة الروسية وبعد ان
البريطانية الاقتصادية كانت خطأ.
اذا ما الصحيح يا سيادة الرئيس
تنتهز الهند الفرصة وعلى طريقة
زعيم كوريا الشمالية. لتعلن
لافتاتهم. الناتو والاتحاد
الاوروبي اتركونا شأننا. بينما
بانظمة دفاع جوية متطورة تمكنها
من حماية نفسها امام طائرات
الايطالية معارضة توريد الاسلحة
الى اوكرانيا والعقوبات المفروضة
كوليبا يطالب بفرض عقوبات على
ايران. تناشد دول اوروبا بدعمها
صناعيا عسكريا ولنضع تحت عسكريا
الف خط. فهل يعلنون بذلك نهاية
تصل روسيا وبوتين يقطع اهم سلعة
يستوردها الغرب من روسيا لتحل
محذرا? الاشتباك المباشر لقوات
الناتو مع الجيش الروسي خطوة
نوع اخر وبعد ان نفذت روسيا
عشرات الهجمات على كييف بطائرات
الانترنت عن اوكرانيا خسائره
الكبيرة وبالتزامن مع عودة
بما يكفي لعدم قبولها. فعن اي
كارثة يتحدث بوتين هنا كارثة من
ماكرون بقسوة وامريكا تلعب على
الحبلين امام السعودية.
وصواريخ روسيا. وعلى ذات السياق
جابت المظاهرات انحاء العاصمة
خطيرة للغاية ستؤدي الى كارثة
عالمية. وامل ان يكونوا اذكياء
حلف الناتو. فماذا فعل بوتين هذه
المرة. بينما ترد موسكو على
الانترنت الفضائي لاوكرانيا
روسيا تطلق صاروخا يحمل قمرا
تلعبها مع الغرب. فرح
الاوكرانيون وقالوا عادت الخدمة
بالضغط على كييب وعلى حلفائها.
ايلون ماسك يعلن تراجعه عن قطع
كوشي ملك. هكذا قالها بوتين في
وجه اولون ماسك. ليأتي الصراخ من
ليرد عليهم بوتين ويقول يا فرح
ما تمت. وهكذا يستمر الروس
تقولها الهند بعد اول تجربة
نووية. فهل يشاركون المجنون
احتفاله? وفي الصين لا مجال
للتراجع. فقد حانت ساعة الصفر
كارثة اكبر من كارثة النفط. فكيف
سيردون ليس هناك وقت للحرب? هكذا
والايطاليون يصرخون في وجه
الناتو. اتركونا وشأننا يا
هؤلاء. طائرات بوتين الانتحارية
تتساقط من سماء كييف. قوات موسكو